[Music]
bye and welcome to episode number 105 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am mock Madol and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warwick how you doing
today I'm good how was Thanksgiving for
you
Thanksgiving was good just hung out with
some friends how about yourself Sam it
was really nice to have some time with
friends and family and food that's my
favorite part of a little holiday yeah
that's true
awesome so this week we have miles
Boren's joining us fellow developer
advocate but active participant in the
node.js community we're gonna have a
good chat with him it'll be fun and that
is still going to be with France s
because Francisco did all these great he
left several weeks back mark and
Francesca and miles will have a good
chat about energy s and also to note
that Google is a platinum sponsor at the
nerd foundation yep yep so we're gonna
talk about that involvement as well and
then after that we're gonna have an
interesting discussion around blameless
post-mortems but how did you
public blameless purse mourners ones
that you share with the outside world
that's always an easy thing to do but
constructive criticism is crucial to
improve things okay but before we get
into all of that let's talk about the
cool things of the week so to get us
started one of the things that I
definitely think is very cool is that
Google has cut the prices on GPUs
specifically the nvidia tesla GPUs which
are attached to our on-demand Google
compute engine virtual machines and
basically it's been cut by about 36%
that's pretty awesome and as well as
that if you're doing sort of a job
processing with GPUs they've also
lowered the price of preemptable local
SSDs by almost 40% compared to
undemanding SSDs basically things are
cheaper cheaper is good cheap breeze
good and GPUs they're popular especially
when you get into machine learning
especially when you get into deep
learning so having machines that you can
use that are cheaper are very helpful
that is good so speaking of doing
machine learning and big compute jobs
and batch processing and all that stuff
we're now offering the skylake cpus in
extra regions that we weren't doing
before so now we have them available in
South Carolina Mumbai and Singapore
joining Iowa Oregon Belgium and Taiwan
bringing the total number of GCP regions
with skylake to seven
nice summons good number 7 is a good
number and just for fun we're also
lowering the price that's even better
yep so lowering the cost of skylake vm's
by 6 to 10% depending on your
configuration seems to be in theme
frankly with the way this last week has
been everything's getting like cut in
price ok it's like ads it's online sales
time it's after Thanksgiving in the US
at least yeah so you know seems like a
common trend last thing we want to
mention is Martin Gardner who's also
developer advocate on our team was
speaking earlier this month at devoxx
and he extended his series he's been
doing around how to do tensorflow
without a PhD or I think deep learning
without a PhD and in this series he's
added on to information around deep
learning and modern convolutional neural
nets as well as he's talking about
Arnon architectures and deep
reinforcement learning so those videos
we have the links to them and we're
gonna be putting them up on our blog
super great resources to learn about all
this stuff it's very it's very helpful
to let people know that you don't have
to necessarily dive deep and spend many
years understanding before you can
experiment with us all right let's go
ahead and dive into the interview so
next up interview with Miles and Mark
and franceska I am very happy today to
welcome a new member of our team
actually another new that has been here
for a while Myles porins how are you
doing else I am doing great and feeling
really new yeah that's good you still
got that new DEA smell though yeah not
looking that new anymore though but
anyway so we have Maus and he's gonna be
joining us to talk about node and we're
gonna be talking about node and the
governance and how he works in all the
open-source organization and all that
stuff but before we start with all of
that whether you tell us a little bit
about yourself what do you do at Google
yeah so as was mentioned my name is
Miles my other name is Boren's together
it's miles Boren's
and I'm a developer advocate on Google
cloud platform I focus primarily on
nodejs but I also you know dabble in
compute and kubernetes and cloud
functions and pretty much anywhere where
you can run node or you know T things
I'm on the technical steering committee
of the node.js foundation
I was recently elected the technical
steering committee director so I also
sit on the board of directors of the
foundation I'm one of the primary
release managers running most of our LTS
programs so most of the version foreign
version six releases and some of the
version eight releases are coming from
me
and lately most of my work has actually
been around v8 and making sure that the
node project can have the most modern
versions of v8 as possible
cool so actually why do we start with
some history I mean most people probably
know what node is but maybe some people
don't so why don't you tell us a little
bit about the language where it came
from sort of what's that background like
yeah totally I can give like I'll give a
super abridged version of the keynote
that I gave at node interactive recently
Google was there we had about like five
different talks and three keynotes and
one of mine was a one of the closing
keynotes and I called it node way of 6
and was just about how like there's been
many different waves of node node was
originally created in 2009 by Ryan Dahl
and presented at James Caan the--you
that would be what we would consider
wave one and Ryan Dahl was the BD FL
which is short for a benevolent dictator
for life of the project or about like I
I think two or three years and then the
project was taken over by Isaac
Schlueter who ran the project for a
similar amount of time and then TJ
Fontaine not TJ all the way check TJ
Fontaine took over for what I would
dubbed node wave three the project was
forked in 2015 into io j s which was
node wave 4 and it was put into a
foundation later that year which was
theoretically node wave 5 and that was
the release of node.js 4.0 since then
node has been in a foundation for the
last two years were up to no js8 right
now no GS 9 is coming out at the end of
this month and yeah like we've been
doing a lot of discussion about node
wave 6 because we're starting to feel a
little bit of the growth pain now and
trying to reimagine some of our
governance and technical direction to
allow us to continue to scale so I think
it's pretty cool that you were
mentioning at least two different
organizations you mentioned the
technical steering committee and you
also mentioned the foundation what are
those let's start with the foundation
for instance what is the node foundation
yeah so
the nodejs foundation is a non-profit I
believe it's a 501 3 C that's like the
thing that nonprofits are maybe got one
of those digits wrong but the foundation
has a number of different member
partners and each of the member partners
donate money based on their membership
level there's silver gold and platinum
Google recently came in as a platinum
sponsor and that actually brought one of
our colleagues Sarah Novotny to the
board of directors which is really
exciting the Board of Directors is made
up of representations one person for
each member from the Platinum level of
sponsorship and then a certain number of
members from both gold and silver
depending on how many sponsors there are
in each of those levels the board of
directors right now is I want to say 11
people and those 11 individuals are
essentially responsible for like the
feudatory duty of the foundation so the
foundation has all this money what do we
use the money for how does it get
handled the foundation itself owns the
code base of nodejs and has lawyers on
hand so you know like if someone decides
to sue us because they think that were
causing problems with licenses and stuff
the foundation would protect us that
actually is a like one thing that's
really great about foundations in
general for open-source software is it
protects all of the maintainer Xand
contributors so if you're a contributor
and you contributed code that may be
somehow down the line had like some GPL
in it and you didn't know the foundation
would be there to support and help you
the technical steering committee and the
board of directors kind of report to
each other although in like a classic
org structure you would maybe see the
board of directors is higher than the
TSC I is the TSC director and kind of
the emissary between both of those
organizations one of the interesting
things about our technical governance
though is that the board of directors
has no technical oversight over the
project in orders of the foundation the
project's technical governance is
completely overseen by the technical
steering committee and the volunteers on
it so the board can't like show up and
be like hey we want you to bake GRP see
into the binaries of node you know that
wouldn't fly but members of the Google
team who are represented on the TSC have
been working really hard to get HTTP to
natively supported not
to flag in notate which will allow us to
have non-binary versions of GR PC so you
can have influence and corporations can
drive influence but not through money
it's through participation action and
engagement so what exactly does the TSE
do so there's a little bit of a loaded
question because we're in the process of
figuring out what the TSE should do what
the TSE has historically done has been
responsible for the overall technical
governance and direction of the project
so this has to do with high-level
initiatives and high-level vision so
we've been doing since April for example
plans for having more modern versions of
v8 in the 8-point X LTS release and
that's involved ongoing work from
various TSE members at the moment
whenever there's kind of certain levels
of technical disagreements those get
floated to the TSE to either have the
technical steering committee itself
reach consensus over or vote if
necessary I think one thing that's worth
mentioning is the technical project of
node itself is governed in a model
called consensus seeking so essentially
any person on the planet can send a pull
request to node and if a committer has
signed off on it and it has been there
for more than 48 hours without anyone
rejecting it we consider that seeking
consensus and it can just land on master
we have a number of processes in place
from testing to CI to smoke testing to
the waterfall of our release process
that offer many different lines of where
we can catch things if they end up being
problematic if they land too quickly but
generally we've been trying to empower
our committers as much as possible and
we try to as much as possible not have
things go to a vote and even further not
go to the technical steering committee
so we had a technical steering committee
meeting this morning for example and we
spent you know the first third of it
talking about the new version of the
eight they recently turned off a scape
analysis because of a bug which makes
async/await slower and so we had to like
do some planning about how are we going
to handle that the other third of it was
spent talking about our build
infrastructure and ways in which we can
make our CI and build infrastructure
more reliable and then a third of it was
spent talking about a document we're
drafting right now on higher level
expectations for leaders in the project
and so you know all those things are
things that are under the purview of the
TSC currently although I'd really like
to see us move the TSC towards more
forward facing proactive initiatives
finding things that need to be done
creating initiatives around it finding
champions and stakeholders to lead those
initiatives rather than the day-to-day
handling of code conflict and finding
more ways to empower our collaborators
to handle that one of the challenges
that we have right now is that as far as
the career growth in the project goes
you become a collaborator and then your
next kind of thing you could do is be on
the steering committee and not everyone
really cares about governance stuff
there's I almost consider it like
similar to like a management track an
individual contributor track in a
corporation and so right now what we're
trying to do is figure out what are more
individual tracks individual contributor
tracks that we can be making for our
collaborators so they can have career
growth and project growth have things
that they can report back to their
organizations about like things that
they're doing and why the money being
invested makes sense and we're actually
we've been talking to Sarah Novotny and
taking some notes from how the
kubernetes project does it and we may do
some iteration based on that so do
something you mentioned something that
sounded almost dangerous to me
especially coming from you know from the
NGO community which is you mentioned
that if someone sends a change to the
language and it has not been rejected
during 48 hours and it passes all tests
and stuff then it just basically gets
merged so can I just go now and like I
don't know do something crazy and add
like I'm gonna add co-routines to no js'
why not you know and I just sent my
change and if I send that on Friday
maybe luckily Saturday and Sunday well
no one will notice and we'll get merged
so three different things there the
first thing there's actually an
extension to the rule for weekends that
make it 72 hours the second would be a
that's good is you would actually need
collaborators to sign off on it so like
we trust our collaborators we give
commits bits there's about a hundred
people with commit bits we trust those
people to make the right decision
if they don't then they have to answer
for it and the third is like our
waterfall release process that we have
offers as I said like maybe it's on
master but we can revert from master
pretty quickly and the last bit is and
this is kind of counterintuitive
we don't actually control the language
at all in node right we embed v8 which
is a JavaScript virtual machine from the
Chrome browser v8 implements the ACMA 2
6 2 specification that's specified by TC
39 which is the Technical Committee that
makes the JavaScript language so we're
actually downstream from the language
itself so we make I know I'm being
pedantic but I just thought people may
be interested in this know that that's
that's a important difference so you
can't go for example I mean like in
theory if you wanted to you could go and
make C++ changes to v8 to change the way
that strings work to be not to the
specification but no one's gonna sign
off on that landing and we have pretty
strict process around like what can land
on v8 and generally we don't land
anything into the v8 tree that hasn't
been approved upstream um so you
mentioned this a couple of times but
let's let's talk about it directly you
talked about how Google is now Platinum
spots uh a Sarah novotny's now on the
board I mean it was so what does that
entail like what is platinum sponsorship
like you talked a little bit about it
and what does it mean now that Google is
part of this program yeah so if you go
to node.js org at the top of the page
there's a link that says Foundation and
if you click on board there you can see
a little bit more information about the
board and who's on there we can notice
that I actually need to send a pull
request cuz Sarah novotny's name is not
on there yet and I'll do that after this
call but the board of directors as far
as you know how the foundation is
concerned what we get
you know we've given a certain amount of
money to the foundation at a platinum
level of sponsorship that gives us a
seat at the board of directors and
having a seat at the board of directors
allows us to have you know to a certain
extent a say and how that money is being
used and how the project is being
supported and how higher-level
initiatives are being done so the
majority of the things that the board
focus is on tend to either be in a
support role to the core project or in a
marketing role to note itself so the
foundation is responsible for throwing
node interact
which was the big conference that we're
at last year and the money that's in the
foundation
you know floats the conference being
able to happen until it gets back you
know the money from ticket sales the
money in the foundation also pays for
the salaries of our executive team so we
have an executive director we have an
education community manager we have a
number of different marketing
individuals that we have on contract
from the Linux Foundation which is worth
mentioning the node foundation is
actually a you know like a child project
through the Linux Foundation who has I'm
definitely not using the correct terms
but the Linux Foundation has like a
process of spinning up foundations under
the Linux Foundation which is how the
node foundation was formed there is
marketing subcommittees and there's like
interest groups that get spun up
depending on you know different things
that need to be done in different
projects that are going on but at the
highest level you know the board is
handling mostly feudatory duties one of
the great things that they signed off on
for example two years ago was creating a
travel fund for collaborators who are
not with member companies to be able to
attend our events and collaborator
summits so I think up until this point
we've probably spent almost 50 thousand
dollars over the last two years flying
out and supporting various collaborators
from the project attending our events
and collaborator summits and actually
any collaborator or even member it's not
always clear but we try to let people
know anyone who's a member of the
foundation which costs $50 is eligible
to apply for a travel stipend generally
these all have to be approved by the
technical steering committee and they're
not going to approve you know
individuals who are not actively
participating but if you're even just
like mildly participating in the project
and you pay 50 bucks or if you even just
get you know a committed and get on a
working group you get that membership
for free you know you can get free trips
around the world on the foundation's
dime to go and collaborate with people
and this is like a really great service
that we offer we have students and we
have education faculty we have people
working for small companies people who
normally wouldn't necessarily get these
opportunities be able to come out and
you know still be a large part of the
project cool and you mentioned that Sara
Novotny is has joined you many people
probably know her from
her work she said in kubernetes you
mentioned she's brought some of her
experience about managing open source
projects from kubernetes over to the
node foundation key there any particular
lessons yeah interesting stories it's
actually like a fun kind of dragon
eating its own tail kind of thing when
the kubernetes foundation was starting
to put together their governance model
was right around the time that I joined
Google and they were really interested
in how node had done things and things
that we thought worked and things that
we thought didn't work I ended up having
you know a call with them I was one of
many people that they ended up
interviewing in the process of coming up
with their governance model and then now
that they've solidified the governance
model and are moving forward with it we
then went back and interviewed them to
find out like hey what did you do and
one of the biggest differences that they
have which as Googlers you're gonna
recognize some of these patterns they
don't actually have an exhibit like the
idea of a committer they have reviewers
they have acceptors they have owners and
they have maintainer x' the maintainer
x' there's only a handful and those are
the only ones who actually have like
ownership over the repo but they
actually have like a commit cubot and so
reviewers can go and review any code
they can like plus one and minus one
things but if an acceptor accepts
something they can totally accept it
even if a reviewer is minus one
something an owner has like veto rights
over all of that I also could be totally
you know not doing justice to how that
actually works this is what I've learned
in like you know the last five days but
from that what we're trying to look at
in node is what kind of level ups for
our committers could we offer and ones
that we're thinking about for example
would be like security a lot of people
want to get more involved in the
security work for the project so we're
looking and this is something we would
talk to the foundation about it would be
like we would go and talk to the board
of directors and say hey can we find
money to create a security training and
onboarding for committers and then when
we create that program which would then
probably also have to go to legal for
due diligence we would be able to take
emitters who are interested and put them
through this onboarding which would then
have them trained for being involved in
handling embargoed security information
and we're looking at changing our
embargo policy right now so that we
bringing more people to review stuff and
have a much smaller team of people who
are actually like handling security
vulnerabilities as they come in
we're talking about spinning up a
mentorship program where like again if
you go through like a certain training
or like a number of different things you
can kind of get a mentorship bit in the
same way that you would get a commitment
and now you can be responsible for
mentoring people in the project so we're
trying to find a handful of different
initiatives like this even potentially
explicitly dividing the difference
between reviewers and Landers of code
which is like kind of straight lifted
from the kubernetes technical governance
structure so all of these sounds very
good but now I'm gonna ask a question
that you might you might not but that's
my job so why does Google pay you to do
this first of all I'm no scrub
referenced referring to the TSE as TLC
just creep along so on top of not being
a scrub Google is investing a lot of
money in node and this includes better
support on App Engine we have quite a
number of like full-time suites who are
working on node related projects such as
stackdriver
or cloud functions node being successful
node working and node being stable and
reliable is part of a major story for us
selling our products and services that
we're building on top of node and
building for use of node I don't have
all of the numbers and I don't want to
say something that's wrong so I'm gonna
hand wave it a little bit but I do know
that I've seen numbers that show down on
like App Engine flex note is one of the
most often spun up platforms on github
javascript is the number one language
guess what number 10 is Pascal
typescript yeah I actually thought us a
go and I was like that's that
I think go is like three or something
and it's growing real fast no but it's
just I mean it's sandwich eating the top
ten and like even just a language that
compiles to JavaScript is one of the
fastest growing platforms that's out
there I think that there's a certain
form of empathy in the code itself and
some of the new patterns that are coming
out in the language such as any single
weight are making it even more
approachable for developers and it's
just really amazing how quickly you can
get up and get running and get
prototypes going and yeah maybe it will
never outperform like really really
really well-written go routines but I
think for a lot of people especially
when you can scale horizontally it's
good enough and they care more about
developer velocity than engineering
purity and that's not to say that you
can't engineer really really cool stuff
with no to but just more in the sense
that like for a lot of teams the
velocity of note is a huge sell and
google has recognized that and is
investing in the platform so having me
kind of like right in there I see it as
kind of hedging the bet it's like they
need to invest on node being healthy and
node being successful or all the other
money is kind of flushed down the toilet
that's a very good point do I get to
keep my job now so you mentioned real
quick that like one of the reasons is
like we actually invest heavily in no
because we also use heavily node and we
provide ways to use node on our Google
cloud platform is there something that
you could share about like what is the
future like it's a typical question that
normally you say no cuz we don't share
much but is there any road map you like
this yeah well one thing that's coming
pretty soon that's exciting is
WebSockets for myself you know like the
first time I ever use node was actually
building an art installation where I
wanted to use a website to pick between
different states and I tried a whole
bunch of different ways of doing it and
I kept failing both gracefully and
miserably and eventually I came across
this tutorial using node and socket IO
and I had a prototype up and running in
like 10 or 15 minutes and that's kind of
to me like that's the magic of node is
like if you've just written a little bit
of website e things you can actually get
something that does what you needed to
do in
a fairly short order WebSockets are a
really really great tool for quickly
prototyping distributed applications
chat applications games which I know
mark has a lot of feelings about and so
this isn't only for node but I do think
that like the eventual support of
WebSockets on App Engine and Google
cloud platform as a whole outside of
just kubernetes is like a huge win for
the various platforms that will get it
and what stuff do you really like about
GCP and node right now so about TCP a
node right now I'm a big fan of cloud
functions I think it's a really cool way
to slowly break away complexity from
applications one of the examples I often
use is just like a mailer so like if
you're having someone who signs up for
like a website for an account and then
when they sign up for the account you
want to like send them a welcome email
or something like that these small
little tasks are easily broken out into
cloud functions things that don't need
to be extremely like performant if they
have a cold boot it's not the end of the
world if they come 30 seconds later it's
not a big deal you know you can really
quickly without a lot of oversight just
break out all this complexity from like
larger scale applications and utilize it
that's one place kubernetes node docker
that stack I'm so excited about you
combine that with like multi cloud and
federating over spaces and I think it's
it's a really oh my god I'm gonna say it
I think it's gonna create a digital
transformation sorry sorry but but
genuinely like I'm really excited about
that technology stack it's not without
its warts but I think you know Google
has first-class support for kubernetes
it's really easy to get started with gke
and there isn't too much of a ritual
that you need to do to get a node app up
and running in a cluster cool what about
node itself what are the things that are
coming up with node that you think are
very exciting yeah so well just last
night I was finishing up our eight-point
7.0 release which is gonna have a newer
version of the 8 6.1 in it there's
discussions that we're going to try to
get v8 6.2 into node 8 which would give
us import as a keyword
which is dynamic import it's part of our
es module support that we're introducing
into node which is pretty exciting well
alright well we are running out of time
but we do like to give our guests the
one shot to be able to say basically
whatever they want Oh is there anything
you want to plug or anything we haven't
managed to mention in today's episode
that you want to make sure I listeners
hear yeah so you know cloud google.com
slash nodejs you can go there to like
just learn about getting started with
node on cloud platform I didn't really
plug stackdriver too much there's some
real magic with stackdriver that you can
do for like live debugging of apps that
are in production you know right nap
with console.log deploy it with stack
driver on GC peeing your logs are just
there and you can just look at them and
that's really cool if you're also
looking at getting started with node
node school dot IO it's a really amazing
place to go and look there's tons of
tutorials that you can run in your
terminal that are really great at
getting people up and running and if you
look it up there's a high probability
that you have a local node school
chapter where you can show up and get
live mentoring to help you through the
problems nice great well miles thank you
so much for taking the time with us
today it was really great to hear all
about node and its governance and how
Google Cloud has been organized well
thank you for inviting me and giving me
some tender loving care as you as you
listen thank you yeah all right well
thanks miles for that that was great it
was good to get some overview of the
node.js foundation and appreciate the
insights that you were able to share I
think it's time for our question of the
week ready I feel like we need a drum
roll for this
how would you do a public blameless
postmortem cool so this is an
interesting topic I am definitely not
gonna claim to be an absolute expert on
it and I'm gonna start referring the
listeners to some other articles but the
whole idea here being is we've talked
about doing play most post mortems on
other episodes about doing sra stuff but
there was a great article that came out
recently from our CRE team our customer
reliability engineering team about how
to do public ones right so something
goes down something bad happens there's
an outage how do you put out a post
mortem basically saying and why should
you put out a post mortem saying like
this is what we're wrong and this is
what we should do so I think there's
there's a lot of things we can talk
about here I think the short version and
I should you should definitely read the
article it's really great it's like why
should you do this and I think the idea
here is also about customer trust so
what would you actually put in a purse
modem so something like why did that
happen
right so what went wrong could it have
been worse and also like how can you
make sure that it didn't happen again so
as a customer you can read this and be
like oh I see something went wrong role
human these things happen but I can see
that you've put things in place now the
Dillion sure that this thing won't
happen again
that aids trust that transparency age
dress and I think that's good for
everyone it's important to be able to
focus on how to improve how to make
things better it's also important to
think about what you don't want to say
and to drive that trust you definitely
don't want to say the names of the
humans involved you don't want to say
the names of the internal systems you
want to avoid customer specific
information so focus on what's went
wrong and talk about it from a how can
we make this better avoid the blame game
yeah absolutely
I definitely be aware of your audience
as well and how much information is the
right amount information and I think
there's there's definitely leeway and
some great area there and in terms of
how you want to do that yeah they make a
great point about you know how much
information too much of information as
well as how much do you want to make
sure is protected you know that you
don't want to give away certain details
about the way your system runs like how
much traffic you have on it so you want
to be a little careful about that as
well but make sure people have enough
information to understand what went
wrong and how that got improved yeah and
there is definitely they link to a bunch
of prior art here as well not to say
like shutting forward or like you know
some really good examples of this being
done where gitlab accidentally deleted
its Postgres database CloudFlare has
some issues I think I meant some issues
we def
we do this a lot too if you look at the
cloud status page little link in the
show notes as well whenever we have an
outage you'll see a little post-mortem
in there as well so definitely have a
look at how we do that internally as
well it's definitely an interesting
thing and I think it's it's good for
customer trust but also as a learning
experience for everyone else who also
builds especially a large distributed
systems great alright I think we covered
the question of the week so mark we're
going to be in the next month next month
or so so yep as I said before I'm gonna
be in Montreal in December speaking at
the Montreal International game summit
I'm going to see of Montreal in winter I
still haven't decided if this is a good
idea you know I've actually done that
one so I would highly recommend bringing
a lot of layers yep heavy coats gloves
but it's really pretty too it can be
really pretty with the snow I can
imagine that what are you up to what are
you doing so at the end of this week I'm
actually participating in the
self-organizing conference on machine
learning that we have at Google and it's
a conference that's bringing in a number
of different external and internal folks
who participate machine learning space
to share knowledge in a very
uncomfortable like to go to in the
machine learning deep learning and
research sciences space known as nips or
neural information processing systems
conference and that's taking place down
in Long Beach and that's all next week
machine learning people really like
their acronyms huh sure do really it's
funny how many acronyms exist out there
all right I think that covers it for us
yeah so Melanie thank you for joining me
this week thank you and thanks to all
our listeners for listening and we'll
see you all next week
you